[Aplausos]
para todos para mí es un honor está aquí
a estar aquí con ustedes
pueden darse cuenta un poquito nerviosa
de verdad porque es un formato nuevo
para mí sin embargo es una experiencia
que creo que vamos a aprender mucho de
ella
y quiero hablarles sobre aprender
viviendo más allá del aula física del
aula de la academia
quiero hablarles
de estas experiencias que uno vive todos
los días
nos dan o nos enseñan cosas que uno de
repente no se da cuenta pero que mirando
restrospectiva sí
para eso he elegido cinco momentos de mi
vida que no tienen absolutamente nada
que ver con la parte laboral y
profesional que probablemente no tengan
ni idea que yo he vivido
en primer lugar
viajar con mi papá los viajes con mi
familia desde muy pequeñas de que tengo
uso de razón hemos viajado por el
interior del perú
viaje que recuerdo con mucho cariño es
uno que hicimos con mis papás el viernes
que el regreso del trabajo y nos dijo
vámonos a tarma
y nos fuimos en el volkswagen todos a
tarma somos tres éramos en esa época
tres mujeres mi mamá y mi papá yo soy la
mayor y de ahí me siguen dos hermanos
pasamos por título y mi papá dijo
paremos el ciclo y mi mamá no porque les
va a dar soroche pero no que bajen que
toquen la nieve que viva la experiencia
entonces fuimos caminando despacito para
que no nos de soroche y tocamos la nieve
jugamos un ratito mamá se acercó y le
dijo por favor
carlos que suban al carro les va a dar
soroche
mi papá le responde deja las déjalas
porque en 30 años no va a haber nieve
perpetua aquí
no le pregunten papá porque quiero un
tema que hace más de 30 años no se
hablaba yo me quedé con la idea de
porque iba me dijo vamos a leer
vamos a investigar sobre el tema
esa experiencia me enseñó a mí dos cosas
lo que él preguntar en el mirar
experiencias diferentes despierta la
curiosidad la creatividad las ganas de
ir más allá de buscar por eso quizás es
que soy bibliotecóloga de primera
primera profesión y segundo que el
conectarte con la naturaleza conectarte
con el entorno te hace ver
cosas que uno de repente en el día a día
no se da cuenta y darte cuenta que debes
cuidar tu entorno que ese entorno que
hoy tienes hay que preservarlo para el
futuro mi papá decía hay que preservarlo
para las siguientes generaciones pero en
realidad para mi propia vida había que
que preservarlo han pasado más de 30
años y si ustedes pasan por ciclos en
distintas épocas del año ya no hay nieve
perfecto
el segundo momento es que yo hice
servicio militar no acuartelado para
mujeres en la marina de guerra del perú
una experiencia ahí está mi diploma para
que es para que no piensen que me estoy
inventando y es una experiencia que
llegó de casualidad
en esa época que teníamos antes que para
que te den la libreta militar hoy el dni
había que si la boleta militar te daban
la boleta y luego la tenías que canjear
por la libreta militar entonces para eso
tenías que ir al ministerio de marina o
del ejército de la aviación yo escogí a
ir a la de la marina así que fui y nos
pusieron en una fila fue con una amiga
de la universidad entonces en esa fila
nos hicieron nos iban haciendo preguntas
una de las preguntas fue saben nadar y
le dijimos sí a entonces también se
desfila los cambiaron de fila y nos
preguntaron qué hacen estudiamos en la
universidad también se define y
desprende de pronto avanzamos y nos
dijeron bueno bienvenidos al servicio
militar no acuartelado de la marina
guerra del perú y nosotros dijimos qué
es esto que hacemos y miami a mí me mira
como diciendo es una aventura hay que
meternos así que estuvimos una
y el servicio militar todos los sábados
muy temprano con nuestro uniforme yo
salía muy temprano en mi casa para que
nadie me viera con uniforme azul dejé de
la marina y marchábamos
preparamos para el desfile militar del
28 de julio desfile en el desfile
militar desde el brasil hasta el final
fue una experiencia muy bonita porque
además de entrenar incluso llegaron a
disparar armas nos enseñaron también a
hacer nado de salvataje
una experiencia realmente increíble y
que además podías escoger entre la
opción de hacer secretariado
telecomunicaciones y enfermería no sabía
nada de enfermería entonces entré a las
clases de enfermería de verdad que yo me
di cuenta que claro en la metodología
era era un poco complicado porque para
la profesora los estudiantes éramos
personas de diversos
background de diversos estratos o
condiciones y era difícil un poco el
tema de cómo enganchar a todos los
estudiantes pero yo quería aprender a
poner inyecciones a hacer vendajes y en
fin y lo logré
también aprendimos algo bien interesante
porque como éramos personas de distintas
condiciones un día estábamos en lo que
se llama el rancho y el rancho es lo que
te sirve no nos servía un sandwich con
jamón con queso una fruta y con mi amiga
dijimos no hay que comer porque estamos
a dieta
una compañera que estaba a nuestro
costado nos dijo chicas que van a hacer
con su rancho no nada lo vamos a dejar
me lo podrán dar sí claro es que es mi
única mi única comida del día y para
nosotros fue muy fuerte porque nos dimos
cuenta de que nuestro entorno nuestra
vida no era la misma estando en la misma
ciudad en el mismo país fue una de las
grandes lecciones lo segundo es que en
la marina era en este servicio militar
nos enseñaron de alguna manera a
respetar al país a que pensemos en que
podemos contribuir a nuestra sociedad y
eso me quedo y también quiero
compartirlo
otra experiencia otro momento importante
fue un programa de visitas
se organizó el gobierno de eeuu y que a
mí me eligieron para ser parte de este
programa por mi trabajo aquí en la
universidad nosotros en las bibliotecas
en la universidad creamos un concepto
nuevo de bibliotecas y el gobierno de
los eeuu lo observó y me llamaron y me
dijeron milagros queremos que vayas a
ver bibliotecas en varias ciudades los
eeuu
eso fue en 1997 fui
con 17 personas cada una de distintas
partes del mundo y recorrimos 6 estados
fue una experiencia maravillosa porque
si ustedes pueden ver en la fotografía
viene una señora de toda de negro ella
es una compañera que hasta el día de hoy
lo es después de muchos años que es de
kyrgyzstán de una de las ex repúblicas
de la unión soviética ella llegó a este
viaje hablando muy poco inglés y era el
único idioma del cual nos podíamos
comunicar yo no sé ruso ella se acercó y
nos dijo a un grupo de personas que ella
casi no hablaba inglés y que si había
alguna forma de entendernos yo no le
entendía mucho y lo que hice fue comprar
un diccionario inglés ruso y entonces
ella me daba algunas palabras yo
inmediatamente
buscaba o con señas mímicas dibujos como
sea trataba de comunicarme con ella y
ella
contando su vida y nos fue contando lo
difícil que fue esta separación de la
unión soviética porque la economía de
cada una de las repúblicas fue cambiando
entonces mientras su sueldo en esa época
era equivalente a 40 dólares al mes a
nosotros en este programa nos daban para
la alimentación y el hospedaje cierto
cerca de 150 dólares al día
entonces ella nos dijo me dijo a mí
milagros tú crees que puedo compartir
habitación contigo y hacía ahorros todos
los días para poder regresar a
kirguistán y poder hacer un viaje desde
allí hasta moscú para visitar a sus
padres con esta división ella había
dejado de ver a sus padres y no tenía
forma de viajar ni ellos tenían forma de
ir a verla así que el eje ya perfecto
entonces compartimos habitaciones en
varios de las
en las que estuvimos y ella logró su
meta
es muy interesante esta experiencia
porque me di cuenta que estas
diferencias estas carencias no solamente
ocurren en nuestro país sino ocurren
también en otras partes del mundo que
somos seres humanos no importa la
cultura que tengamos vivimos los mismos
sentimos lo mismo experimentar lo mismo
tenemos las mismas preocupaciones
lo otro que también aprendí de este
viaje es las distintas culturas que
pudimos haber estado juntos es que cada
cultura tiene algo que aportar algo que
nos enseña algo que nos enriquece en vez
de vivir y dividir
no suma
cuarta experiencia navegar en un velero
sánchez yo aprendí a navegar en un
velero cerca de los 40 años ya mayor
es una experiencia maravillosa
lo hice porque mi hija ha sido un
deporte un mérito un optimismo y ella ha
llegado a competir por el perú embargo
yo no conocía no sabía del deporte mucho
no sabía si porque ganaba porque perdía
entonces oso decidimos
recibimos a aprender aprendimos
estábamos en la academia del club y el
club tiene su equipo y cuando de los que
estábamos en la academia escogieron a
los a los participantes a mí no me
escogieron
yo dije por qué no no lo había hecho
también entonces cuando llamaron a mi
esposo para ser parte del equipo yo
pregunté si yo podía ir a la reunión
bueno fui a la reunión y fue parte del
equipo
con la persistencia y la persistencia
logré en un año ser subcampeona nacional
más desarrollo
gracias
y aquí aprendí dos cosas uno que uno
tiene si uno tiene miedos porque yo
tenía miedo de entrar al bote no me daba
cuenta me temblaban las piernas siempre
quería que alguien entrara antes que yo
porque tenía miedo de de sentarme en el
bote y que no avanzara pues no avanzaba
muchas veces hasta que logré que
avanzara tome el timón y lescott ahora
esta cuerda que sujeta la vela y avanzó
el bote tan feliz así como cuando uno
aprende a montar bicicleta por primera
vez cuando ya no le agarran del cuello
le quita las rueditas esa sensación y
ahí aprendí eso que uno debe insistir
persistir que aunque tengan los miedos
hay que vencerlos
segundo en un bote en un velero cuando
no te salen bien las cosas el bote se
puede voltear y tú te volteas con el
bote
enseñan a colocarlo en su lugar
eso da miedo da mucho miedo los cables
las cuerdas se enredan en la cabeza se
te va el gorro se le van los lentes
entonces tienes que ver la forma como
volver a ponerte tú dentro del bote
también y eso es parte de esta enseñanza
de que yo aprendí de seguir aunque algo
esté peor no importa calma y hay que
resolverlo
el último momento los logros
curriculares de nuestros alumnos para mí
es una gran satisfacción haber
participado y sido parte de él
son de luz y de música peruana del
elenco de música peruana de los
estudiantes ellos han presentado este
disco lo han hecho con mucha pasión cada
uno ha puesto lo mejor de sí ha
rescatado la cultura peruana y han
interpretado y compuesto un civic está
disponible en spotify pero si buscan
pero un sonido ahí está y están las
canciones de este disco realmente me
sentí recordando lo que decía mi papá
respecto al ambiente al perú y respecto
a lo que dice la marina ese sentido de
ser parte de algo de dar algo por
nuestro país de contribuir y si yo
contribuyo otra vez de que otros
contribuyan como todos ustedes aquí en
la universidad
eso para mí me llena
aprender viviendo piense ustedes en
momentos de su vida donde hayan
aprendido algo donde estén aprendiendo
algo más allá de las aulas más allá de
lo académico cuántas cosas vivimos lo
que yo les recomiendo es que aprendan
todos los días experimenten
no tenga miedo y si lo tienen van para
vayan para adelante porque la vida es
eso la vida es un aprendizaje la vida es
un camino solo tenemos una vida y hay
que disfrutarla a pesar de lo difícil
que pueden ser algunos momentos estamos
aquí por algo estamos aquí por algo está
nuestro recorrido y muchas de las cosas
que hemos aprendido en nuestra vida
hacen que seamos lo que somos y lo que
nos figure los configura para el futuro
pero que sigan aprendiendo dentro y
fuera de la universidad muchas
[Aplausos]
[Música]